[Music]
these lizards are leaping for science
well not so much leaping is falling but
their tumbles are helping scientists
answer a question could hurricanes drive
natural selection hurricanes are
destructive perhaps too destructive to
influence evolution with species
survival being more random than
influenced by specific traits and while
some scientists suspect that hurricanes
could drive natural selection this has
never been documented that is until a
group of researchers happen to be
measuring anole lizards in the Caribbean
they surveyed lizards on two small
islands in Turks and Caicos just days
before hurricanes Irma and Maria struck
winds reached speeds of more than 200
km/h felling trees and flattening
vegetation but after the devastation the
scientists had a rare opportunity to see
how the Hurricanes affected the lizard
populations they went back and measured
the lizard's left on the islands on
average those that survived had larger
toe pads and shorter femurs the male's
also had smaller bodies researchers
suspect that these small differences
might help the animals cope with high
winds but how well that brings us back
to lizards falling into Nets this simple
test done with a leaf blower who
demonstrates how they respond to high
wind
[Music]
to stay on the branch the lizards tuck
their forelegs under their body and out
of the wind but their hind legs stick
out catching the wind until they
ultimately lose their grip the
scientists say that shorter femurs and
smaller bodies could help them hang on
additionally the lizard's toe pads are
covered in tiny ridges larger pads means
more ridges and so better grip right now
this is mostly speculation but it could
explain the differences the researchers
measured after the Hurricanes and that
raises the possibility that hurricanes
could act as a selection pressure
favoring lizards with wind resistant
traits and if the traits stay in the
population that could drive evolution
picking apart processes like this will
help conservationists predict how
ecosystems adapt to extreme weather
events which we'll see more of as the
climate warms but for now let's
appreciate these little anoles for their
contribution to evolutionary science
[Music]